el concierto que aún recuerdas y que te
emocionas
ese viaje a las pirámides la ciudad más
bella
los cuerpos perfectos del movimiento
la creación
el libro que te cambió la vida
el arte que abolió los muros el arte
como diría nietzsche sin arte la vida
sería un error y creo que es un acierto
el día de hoy hablar sobre los artistas
sobre las personas que dedicamos la vida
esto
ok vamos a hacerlo interactivo yo les
digo unas palabras y a ver qué se nos
viene a la mente genios del arte
picasso y ahí da vinci claro miguel
ángel mentes privilegiadas casi divinas
no ahora vidas de artistas
frida kahlo
van gogh tal y claro amadeo modigliani
vidas marcadas por la tragedia por los
excesos que quizás estos artistas no
fueron tomados en cuenta murieron pobres
y hoy recuperados por la historia pues
son famosísimo si su obras se venden
miles no arte actual con un gran signo
de de dólares
grandes subastas no ahora el arte es
dinero solo eso
estos personajes de mía hills con su
calavera de 72 millones de euros está tu
será lo que tom wolfe diría que ese es
el grupo pequeño de personas interesadas
en el arte con muchísimo dinero y que
dictan que es arte que no es arte cuáles
son las tendencias no tanto por el arte
sino por el mercado del arte y si les
pregunto por algún artista local ahí ya
se pone un poquito más complicado
gracias pero por ejemplo si tu hijo
llega terminando la prepa y te dice me
quiero dedicar al arte no sé si hacerlo
de forma autodidacta o estudiar artes
plásticas papá
drama familiar si si estudiar
humanidades está estigmatizado ya
estudiar arte ya imaginamos realidades
muy difíciles
él nunca va a tener un trabajo real no
se puede vivir del arte ese es el
paradigma y bueno yo metí a google
artista hambriento extraordinario y eso
bueno me salieron cosas muy chistosas
pero esto creo que fue el mejor verdad y
pena su musa y sólo piensa en una
hamburguesa
el día de hoy yo voy a hablarte del
artista emprendedor
soy alejandra felt soy artista visual yo
vivo del arte y este me encantaría que
después de esta charla detecte tengas
otra mirada sobre el artista profesional
sobre el artista emprendedor cuando
nosotros hablamos de emprendimiento casi
siempre pensamos lo relacionamos con los
empresarios el dinero no al éxito desde
esa perspectiva pero emprender puede
tener motivaciones muy distintas en mi
caso pues es seguir produciendo hasta
que sea una viejita y este porque yo amo
el arte y pues también sacar adelante a
mi familia de manera digna como todos
ustedes verdad
y yo aquí les voy a dar algunas
características también para los
artistas emergentes me gustaría que
vieran de qué es esto de qué va esto de
ser un artista profesional y pues las
familias de los artistas también
entonces yo aquí planteo características
del artista emprendedor pues la primera
es el coraje hay que tener coraje hay
que tener conocimiento hay que tener una
propuesta artística de valor ser
perseverante formar tu equipo de trabajo
organizar su tiempo las relaciones
públicas son importantes y también obvio
la innovación coraje puse esta foto
porque uno empieza con un gran anhelo tú
sabes que eres artista sabes que tienes
talento es algo muy grande pero a la vez
es muy poco a nadie le importa que
tengas talento y nadie va a venir a
descubrirlo es la realidad aparte la
gente que crees que te va a ayudar en la
que no te ayuda son otras personas las
que se van a sumar a tu proyecto que se
van a poner la camiseta entonces el
inicio es duro y pongo esa foto porque
hay dos personajes primero la mas
cachetona soy yo a la edad de 17 años yo
empecé con mi idea de salir de mexicalli
tuve como 5 trabajos no tenía permiso ni
dinero y me fui a estudiar con una beca
a francia- filosofía con ellas organicé
este viaje italia y la del centro la de
camisa negra ellas a mi es dulce l ella
es escultora era mi compañera en la
escuela y en la primera artista de carne
y hueso que yo conocí
creo que desde entonces a 20 años nos
saquen cuentas pero a 20 años de esto no
ha habido un solo día que no haya
requerido coraje y ganas pero en una
alegría de saber me artista eso sí se
los puedo decir el conocimiento el
artista necesita con ser
primero tener un conocimiento teórico
para el concepto de lo que va a ser
necesitas también un conocimiento
técnico para realizarlo y también
necesitas un conocimiento de la historia
del arte aparte de eso vas a necesitar
conocimiento del mercado galerías los
dealers ese mundillo del arte donde vas
a insertar tu trabajo y también tienes
que conocer las instituciones a veces la
gente piensa que los artistas estamos
así en la tarde que nos tomamos una copa
de vino es yus estoy inspirado o no
estoy inspirado
el artista se prepara muchísimo a los
artistas tenemos que ser personas cultas
para poder producir tener una propuesta
como diría francis bacon un hombre sabio
construirá más oportunidades de las que
encuentra
tienes que tener una propuesta artística
de valor a veces pensamos que el artista
vale por por el precio de su obra porque
vende muy caro también pensamos que el
artista vale porque inscribe sus nombres
letras doradas en la historia del arte
de su país o del mundo pero la realidad
es que habemos muchísimos artistas
profesionales alrededor del mundo que
estamos incidiendo y estamos
cooperando para que este mundo sea mejor
en el terreno de la educación de la
psicología del urbanismo de la ecología
y de muchas otras cosas
yo quiero hablarles de la de dos
propuestas la primera es el arte
alimenta que es un proyecto que tengo
desde hace 13 años
es un proyecto de arteterapia que es ha
calendarizado anualmente trabajamos con
niños con refugiados
que llegan a la zona y les ayudamos pues
a estar más tranquilos a bajarle los
niveles de ansiedad como terapia
ocupacional pero también a desarrollar
otras habilidades porque el arte te
ayuda a desarrollar muchísimo
otro proyecto del que quiero es de mi
proyecto mi último proyecto retratos
iluminados
nosotros somos cinco hermanas yo soy la
más chica
puras mujeres en mi familia muchas tías
entonces creo que puedo hablar de lo
femenino pero lo que yo había visto de
lo que yo había leído de arte de género
me parecía como muy contestatario muy en
lo negativo en la herida no y se respeta
pero yo quería hacer otra cosa entonces
hice un proyecto en pintura en
fotografía
y en
arte objeto donde privilegia mucho lo
que era el aspecto técnico
y bueno este es un performance también
hice de cortos performance y a lo que
quiero llegar es que tuvo mucho impacto
en el sentido de que este proyecto lo
expuse en asia lo expuse en europa lo
expuse acá en eeuu les voy a contar una
anécdota de una señora de china que me
con la ayuda de google traductor me
escribió y me contó que ella tenía dos
años sin hablarle a su única hermana que
fue a mi exposición que vio una pieza
que le llamó mucho la atención y que le
mando un mensaje a su hermana y que le
dijo ve a la exposición y después si
quieres háblame pues total que de la
hermana fue se reconciliaron
un señor bueno esta es una historia otro
señor me platicó de su abuela que lo
crió por ejemplo y me contó una historia
era fue muy sorprendente todos los
mensajes y la gente en las exhibiciones
como me contaba su vida creo que ahí yo
pude aportar valor a la vida de las
personas
relaciones públicas
bueno aquí estoy en una exhibición con
mucha gente uno se pone nervioso acá
estoy en mónaco donde están las chicas
las estudiantes de rosa estoy en yakarta
en indonesia abajo estoy en china acá
estoy en una reunión de eran como 600
alumnos es lógico que a veces uno se
pone nervioso es lógico que a veces uno
no anda con toda la disposición es
difícil aprender de los códigos o los
protocolos en los diferentes países a mí
lo que me ha funcionado de ser yo misma
estar abierta a que las otras personas
más que yo contar algo que ellas me
cuenten
creo que las poses
se alejan de las personas
la perseverancia como dijo da vinci si
una persona es perseverante aunque le
cueste entender se hará inteligente y
aunque sea débil se volverá fuerte la
perseverancia es la clave de la
evolución organizar el tiempo hacer
metas a corto mediano y largo plazo eso
es esencial formar tu equipo de trabajo
con personas que se pongan la camiseta
que crean en tu proyecto al inicio serás
un hombre orquesta esto es normal pero
después busca privilegiar el trabajo que
tú mejor sabes hacer
en mi caso hacer arte nadie más lo puede
hacer y los demás pueden hacer
profesionalmente lo que les toca y bueno
todo resulta mucho mejor y la innovación
esta frase que me encanta en mandela
siempre parece imposible hasta que se
hace y les voy a hablar del proyecto que
acabamos de hacer aquí con set y su
universidad un encuentro de artistas
donde reunimos a 37 artistas de 20
nacionalidades
formamos la primera colección de arte
internacional del noroeste tuvimos una
interacción maravillosa con los alumnos
lleno total en el museo
y sobre todo algo súper positivo tenemos
ahora 37 embajadores que hablan de la
frontera norte de baja california de una
manera distinta
para finalizar esta frase de la
escritora emily dickinson ignoramos
nuestra verdadera estatura hasta que nos
ponemos de pie yo hoy estoy aquí de pie
invito a todos los artistas emergentes a
que se profesionalicen a que sean
artistas emprendedores y al público en
general a que tengan otra mirada sobre
los artistas emprendedores los artistas
profesionales gracias